what's up is Kelsea Ballerini and you're
watching certified countries the Sophie
[Music]
welcome back to certified country i'm
sophie scholl AC and there is so much
love in the air today I'm giving you a
first listen to Kelsea Ballerini
perfectly gushy new love song written
for fiance we're catching up with Justin
more about welcoming baby number four
and I'm putting Kellie Pickler and hubby
Kyle Jacobs relationship to the test
spoiler alert they passed with flying
colors laughter you guys sat down with
Kelly and Kyle in New York City at
Justin Timberlake's southern hospitality
barbecue restaurant and I wanted to see
whether these two still have that
newlywed glow he's been married six
years together for 10
uh-huh I want to play a better than
newlywed game better than newlyweds
better than new perfed only gets better
the longer you married right absolutely
okay right right right right right
if your spouse had a superpower what
would it be
pre-clear Lamanna don't flatter yourself
I would say you would fly like no or
that I just am fly but no like you could
fly just languages remember man and all
those people I think since my wife is so
intuitive if she had a superpower okay
she would do read mine what is the first
thing your spouse would buy if they won
the lottery
you can't touch shoes you can't put use
I'm gonna play this because I have said
this is what you would want to buy for
us to enjoy together that's an island
whoo that's a good one vacation for a
year on a beach yeah high-five on that
one yeah challenge of it
what word best describes your spouse in
the morning in the morning before or
after coffee before before coughing I've
had Pepe even before coffee Pepe it's
that weird puppy well you got like a
little spring of mush oh yeah do not
talk to her before coffee just don't do
it okay who is your spouse's Hall Pass
well but we never would just say well I
wouldn't do that but hi
having said that okay I know yours yeah
I know how to say your name but I don't
have a cell that's okay hey back and so
those are some good ones oh thank you
she liked that boy you could ask
yourself question do I feel lucky
well do you okay okay this is the last
one you guys how would your spouse
describe the perfect weekend the perfect
weekend I want to say something but I
don't think I should give inappropriate
yeah okay eighty Astrid are all right I
just thought spending time together
laughing mine was getting a cabin maybe
a hot air balloon ride drink a little
bit of wine aha etc expanding that
around from an appropriate hour perfect
for me
[Laughter]
Holly and Kyle are back on CMT for the
third season of I love Kellie Pickler
airing Thursdays at 11:00 p.m. Eastern
and Pacific now while I was hanging with
those two in New York Justin Moore was
in Los Angeles and my friend Katie
Krauss sat down with him right here in
our studio to find out how life has
changed since welcoming his first
assignment Thomas south it seems like
every time I put an album out I have
kids so is that how it is I may not put
another album ala but this may be the
last one so it's definitely last kid so
but now we're very blessed my wife and I
have three daughters and just recently
in her first little boy south and he's
seven weeks right it's a controlled
chaos around our house for the most part
everything in our lives and our homes
have been geared or little girls four
four seven eight years now and I could
change the little girl's diaper with one
hand tied behind my back blindfolded in
a matter of a few seconds but the first
diaper is I changed it took me like 15
20 minutes I'm going I don't know what
to do with all this this stuff happening
down here what if I want to get into
music I'm going to push and push and
push the opposite direction I would
prefer that they didn't have to deal
with some of the fun
that I've dealt with over the course of
my career but obviously if you know
they're passionate about music or
anything for that matter
we'll be supportive I'm crossing my
fingers that they don't want to leave
home at 18 like I did I want them all
drop by me somebody how do you Nate me
did you have a good pick-up line no in
the trashiest most redneck hillbilly way
possible we actually went on senior trip
out of high school Panama City Florida
our hotel rooms we were sharing
balconies and so my wife and I talked
and and we've been together ever since I
actually signed my record deal on our
wedding night which was kind of crazy I
didn't tell her that for a while because
I don't want her to think that that was
more important okay now that's a good
husband Justin said his manager actually
brought his recording contract to their
wedding reception ten years ago and he
signed it right then and there now
kicking off the song picks of this week
is miss bride-to-be
Kelsea Ballerini and her brand-new track
unapologetically which was written for
her fiance Morgan Evans here's your
first listen
[Music]
we answer
[Music]
directly off
from a second master Molly
[Music]
healthy actually spilled the beans about
that song in an interview with me back
in February take a look at what she had
to say about it back fat have you
written any songs about Morgan yes and
he just sang on it
and it's gonna be on the record and it's
cheesy and I like it
well I'm really excited for that I mean
ah but it's called I can't yeah cuz I
think it's gonna end up being the the
album title so I'm over pulling all that
but yeah it'll it'll be there well
Kelsey made good on that promise
unapologetically the album is out on
November 3rd and if you preorder it
right now you'll get to download the
title track instantly meanwhile Brett
Eldredge is self-titled album is out
right now and I'm really loving the song
castaway which Bret has also said is one
of his favorites take a listen what I
was going to do I guess I'll always be
alright I'll leave you with one more
upbeat love song for today that's
unforgettable by Thomas Rhett
[Music]
knocking Spacely
so that night was just like you
swoon Tom isn't it like Lauren are the
ultimate couples goals as far as I'm
concerned they're so cute
all right guys that'll do it for me
today do me a favor they'll find me over
on Instagram I am at Sophia Lacy and say
hello and while you're at it please be
sure to LIKE comment and subscribe right
here we'll see you again next Friday
till then happy listening